so if you like the best place for us to
begin is at the beginning so I want you
all to break it down and let us know how
each of you actually came to know mother
rue and how we were invited to be a
judge on the show picture it 1987 Sicily
New York City close close Copacabana
Susanne bartsch
parties and rue was there and I was
there and love affair happened no really
I just saw you and it was kind of like
rue would be double fisting the drinks
at the time walking through the party
and be like hey girl hey girl and that
kind of journey happened for a few years
and then 1989 happened and I was in a
girl group yeah
called seduction now called reduction we
were still in the clubs and he would
watch me and then 1992 happened in a
little song called supermodel and a
little song called it's gonna be a
lovely day happened yes at the same time
and we saw each other this is a moment
that I'll never forget we saw each other
at the new or dance music seminar in New
York City at the Marriott Marquis and we
were in a green room and rue walked in
and I was like I don't know if you
remember me but and as I went to say Who
I was he said [ __ ] I've been remember
you I've been watching you for years he
said you looked me dead in the eyes and
said you a superstar and literally I was
like nobody ever said that but my mother
and that was like yeah in my head I knew
that I was you know Madonna 2.0 my music
career didn't know that but rue said it
so I was kind of validated in that
moment and then this is where it all
began 1996 wkt you in New York City
launched I had somehow hustled my way
into a radio career with no experience
that's the microphone and then RuPaul
often they put us together for Fashion
Week
he didn't know that I was gonna be there
I didn't know that he was gonna be that
he walked in and looked at me when of
all the people of course it's you
sitting there they put us together the
rest is history he brought me on as his
sidekick on the RuPaul talk show on vh1
and that's where Mary and Rhoda began
I'm Rhoda obviously joel mchale question
mark go it was just like hashed it's
like hashtag enough you know it was like
when straight guys walk into a gay bar
but treat it like a sports bar and I
would I'm always considerate of our
guest judges always because they are our
guests and I you know look that they're
there and they're all super fans but I
think he thought it was funny and I love
Joel but then I kind of just had enough
like I had my JLo moment let's bring him
out ladies and gentleman
[Applause]
I'd be good I'd be good we literally
afterwards he literally was like you
know in boxing me and and we have a
great relationship but it was really
really funny because at that moment I
didn't know him as well as I know now
but it was the moment did you did you
watch the episode yeah I watched it I
mean the editors kept like a lot of
Michelle's like shade outside but that
was after 20 minutes two of them so what
did he make it and remember I mean
exactly the other stuff but yeah it was
a lot there what am I really am i lying
right they cut out like my ear by the
way right in my ear and they cut out
like 80% of how many times you went yeah
Ross I've never heard you so manly oh my
god honestly hurt to do that
you have so much to offer so many
different perspectives to offer these
Queens so what are you thinking
specifically and what are you looking
for from the Queens let's talk
lip-synchs and main stage challenges
anything in particularly you're looking
for from these Queens to get to you yeah
I think my judging style is quite
different to everybody else's on the
panel and that's okay I think mostly
because yes I'm a fan of them but I also
there's a sense of integration for me
because I grew up I was weaned off the
cotton teats of drag queens I was 17
years old when I became involved in the
community through the ballroom scene and
I I was always with drag queens and
trans people who are not called trans
people but trans women who were
performing as drag queens or drag
performers so for me I've seen the best
of the best and I've seen how you could
get better with time I've seen it all
and I've lived through it all with
Queens hand at hand arm and arm so it's
different than going and seeing a bunch
of shows I've been in the trenches with
them so when I look for something it's
the challenge of course what they're
supposed to do and if the challenge is
being met and it's are they doing this
to the best of their ability also are
they doing something that's different
every week because for me I know as an
actor and as a performer you get
typecast really easily especially in
Hollywood and I know all these girls
have dreams of going on and doing things
and making the most money that they can
make in a limited amount of time we
don't know how long we've got so we got
to live in the moment
so if I see them kind of coasting on
what they do best I feel like there
could be room for elevation and I want
them for two casting directors to look
at them and go oh not only can she do
that but she girls who do that that and
that done signed her I walk that for
them so they can make the most out of
their career in the shortest amount of
time and make the most amount of money
and I don't want them to be lazy cuz
lazy don't get you nowhere